and just into our Newsroom here at 4 30
a break in two Cold Case murders from
the 90s Metro Police have now linked
Eddie George Snowden Jr to raping and
killing two Las Vegas women Brian will
was at the news conference this
afternoon and joins us now with more
details Brian yeah Metro Police say DNA
from a family member of Eddie George
Snowden Jr LED them to the killer in
both of these cases the victims are 31
year old Laura and pierra and 35 year
old Pearl Wilson Ingram pierra's body
was found on December 11 1992 in the
area of East Charleston near Fremont
Street she was found nude and bound with
duct tape she was strangled Ingram was
found in similar circumstances on
January 12 1994 in a dumpster near East
Charleston and lamb police say Snowden
lived in that area Ingram's younger
sister Teresa board says her sister was
known as Pinky and was a lively fun
mother to her son
my sister was educated she was a mother
she was a sister
she was the aunt
and she didn't get to
become a grandmother and that's not fair
board is thankful to Metro and everyone
involved in helping bring her and the
other family some closure Metro is
encouraging other departments where
Snowden Jr lived including Fresno
Sacramento Sano Cruz as well as other
surrounding cities to review their cases
in case he is linked to a crime there
reporting live in The Newsroom Brian
will 8 News Now